hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video schon im titel wahrscheinlich dass
wieder irgendwas komisch ist im bilde
und immer wenn etwas komisches
zwischenspielen wir wohl yoopress
was mache ich hier mit meinen händen
real yoopress rabatten ist eine website
wo wir auf der einen seite etwas
vorgeschlagen haben und auf der anderen
seite das was passiert wenn wir ja sagen
dass ich wir fangen einfach mal an und
das erklärt sich dann glaube ich von
selbst auf der einen seite bekommen wir
unmengen an geld also viel geld wie wir
haben wollen auf der anderen seite
werden wir den nächsten zehn jahren
immer mehr depressiv und töten uns dann
irgendwann nach zehn jahren ist einem
geld wichtiger als leben ich bin ich
habe ihr angehört wie dieser galileo
mensch aiman abdallah heiße glaube ich
der immer so sagte jammer ist es denn
wirklich so muss das wirklich so sein
ist als geld wichtiger als leben ich
würde auf keinen fall den knopf drücken
wenn ich für unlimitiertes geld okay ich
bin in der mehrheit mit 66 usd internet
whether you go but the boers
internetprovider label ok das heißt
jetzt auf deutsch übersetzt wir haben
überall internet egal wo wir hingehen
seiten einer höhle im tunnel irgendwo
auf mond im weltraum was weiß ich aber
immer die beschissene leitung würde ich
klopfe nicht drücken mehrheit
okay das ist jetzt sehr einfach für mich
würde ich sagen und zwar kann ich auf
der einen seite die frau heiraten nicht
schon immer heiraten wollten kein
perfektes leben führen auf der anderen
seite muss ich 24 stunden am tag sieben
tage in der woche einen hut tragen
ich glaube für dora ist ein hut ich
würde definitiv den knopf drücken und
bin mit 72 prozent in der mehrheit alter
ich finde hüte jetzt nicht mal schlimm
das ist für mich jetzt auch relativ
einfach und zwar auf der einen seite
wissen wir alles was irgendwie in
unserem universum vor sich geht also sei
es über allem
über alle songs aliens gibt über alle
planeten auf der anderen seite wenn ich
es jemandem erzähle muss ich direkt
pinkeln geh ich halt einfach aufs klo
dicker wenn ich auf den knopf drücke bin
ich mit 55 mal wieder in der mehrheit
irgendwie bin ich heute tatsächlich nur
der mehrheit ich habe die macht
unsichtbar zu werden auf der anderen
seite kann ich mir immer in die hosen
wenn ich das an wände
ich würde sagen wenn ich das nämlich an
wände und unsichtbar bin bin ich ja
quasi unsichtbar und wenn ich mich dann
halt an scheiße dann bin ich ja quasi
immer noch unsichtbar und wenn ich dann
wieder sichtbar werde werde ich einfach
erst sichtbar wenn ich wieder bei mir zu
hause bin das heißt ich werde einfach
nur unsichtbar werden wenn ich irgendwie
nackt bin und dann werde ich nur dann
irgendwie unsichtbar sein walter
versteht ihr wie ich meine
mit 55 prozent in der mehrheit aller
juckt mich ist's her hatten wir wirklich
nur sachen wo man wirklich mal
nachdenken musste also was die ok würde
ich für unlimitiertes geld allen sagen
dass ich nur zehn jahre noch leben habe
und so das war alles schon mega krass
und brenntag jetzt allerdings your
partner max muster widge.de switches
bacon yours das nord also unser partner
unternehmenspartner macht uns ein
sandwich auf also das set von denen hat
allerdings bacon in unsere es nicht
natürlich sondern mir noch einen switch
machen also ob ist es scheißegal 73
prozent
ohne spaß so ey ich bin heute nur in der
mehrheit ihr könnt mir nichts
sie bekamen den most talented musician
in die world any instrument but you
can't turn any money from your talent
ist doch scheißegal ich verstehe solche
fragen immer nie beziehungsweise ich
verstehe die leute nicht die daran sagen
würden mache ich nicht weil ich meine
wenn ich jetzt auf den knopf drücken
heißt es ja nur ich kann jetzt zum
beispiel wenn ich mir die gitarre
aussuche mega gut gitarre spielen wie
kein anderer mensch auf der welt aber
damit kann ich ja kein geld verdienen
aber wenn ich nicht auf den knopf
drücken kann ich dann nicht mehr gitarre
spielen
ich argumentiere jede frage mega krass
warum sind 32 prozent dagegen also ich
bin in der mehrheit mit 68 aber etwas
denkt ihr euch dabei seid ihr dumm
diese frage ist krass und zwar days of
the present tense in der die uniqa motto
also dass man eine 50 prozentige chance
dass man unsterblich wird allerdings der
es aus soll 50 cent change the world
das ist kompletter kopf ich gerade wisst
ihr ich komme gerade aus der uni und
habe gerade vier stunden
wirtschaftsrecht ecke jura hinter mir
und mein kopf explodiert und jetzt sehe
ich hier solche fragen und denke mir
okay ich nehme jetzt ein video auf aber
das strengt mich grad mehr an
würd ich das machen ich glaube ich bin
wirklich der einzige mensch der
unsterblichkeit nicht geil findet weil
irgendwann ich weiß nicht wird man dann
immer älter oder ist man unsterblich bei
dem alter wo man sich gerade befindet
also ich würde auf keinen fall den knopf
drücken und ich würde der minderheit
sind hier alle lebensmüde dem motto back
up die erste news flow den space rating
von death or never come das ist nämlich
genau die sache irgendwann wird die erde
verreckt so das ist jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen subtil irgendwie ausgedrückt
von mir aber irgendwann sind wir alle
tot wenn ich dann der einzige lebende
mensch bin und irgendwo im universum um
fliege oder so ey dann will ich doch
einfach nur noch sterben
allein dieser kommentar hat diese ganzen
leute die auf den knopf gedrückt haben
einfach mega hochgenommen
an dieser stelle will ich jetzt auch mal
das video beenden meine damen und herren
es euch gefallen hat lassen leid damit
macht das immer mega viel spaß weil ich
da einfach mega cool kommentieren kann
schreibt mir mal bitte in die kommentare
wo ihr anders geantwortet hätte als ich
beispielsweise hättet ihr hier ist bei
der letzten sache auch auf jage drückt
ich gehe das risiko ein und 50 prozent
sterblichkeit aber 50 prozent kann ich
vielleicht auch unsterblich werden hier
findet ihr ein video eingeblendet was
bestimmt auch irgendwie cool ist die
version was der verlinkt werden und hier
findet ihr oben ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren auch sehr cool weil ich dann
halt ein neues abo habe
und ja ich glaube ich muss nicht
erklären was ein abonnement bringt aber
ich verabschiede mich an der stelle
haut rein